okay i'm louis and i'm charlie and we
have been told and we believe that we
have the largest private collection of
insects in the world yeah the story of
how we met was interesting enough i was
a teaching assistant at the university
of arizona and Louis was a student in
the class that I was teaching we've been
married for almost 55 years he's got a
million stories about insects all of
which I've heard and all of which I can
fill in sentences and we've traveled
extensively have been to all the
continents and 70 countries collecting
it fills us with pleasure to get into
the field and collect to spend the time
in the field together oh you need to
look at the antenna on one of these it
looks like a clown shoe well I study
weevils and the weevils are the largest
family of living organisms these are
plant hoppers and I think their noses
are - I collect plant hoppers which are
insects that feed on the juices of
plants the foam or the xylem with
piercing sucking mouthparts with
piercing sucking mouthparts
oh yeah
when when we get some insects in there
just dead of course we have to mount
them so we have to pin them our point
point them and then we label um ah blue
was not stiff enough and he's fallen off
his point then after I do that then I
sort him to genus each of these units
trays holds 55 specimens on average and
we have at least a million weevils and a
quarter of a million flying hours
okay here you go darling we are donating
the collection to Arizona State
University and there will be research
done on it which is what we wanted to
have happen when we were entomologist at
the University we've worked 14 hours a
day seven days a week now we're down to
eight to ten hours a day seven days a
week it's a lot of work but we both
loved what we were doing and it was
sharing that it was part of our life
yeah which one do you think is the
prettiest these two I don't like that
one Louis has often taken note of the
fact that a very large number of
entomologists are divorced what I
recommend is if you're going to be a tax
on Alyssa systematists collect insects
you get a spouse is another entomologist
you
this has always been an obsession
everybody collects something and mine
just happens to be Alice
[Music]
my name is Jim philipson on the antler
mat I have over $16,000
I didn't kill all these animals to get
the elders I'm not much for killer deer
and elk and moose and antelope shed
their antlers every year and grow a new
set of antlers I just started walking
out in the hills and I would find one
and pick it up and bring it home
there is no harm to the animal I have
good days and bad days
the most deer antlers I ever found in
the day was 87 but I hiked 11 hours and
never found an antler
I keep my antlers in a shed that I built
at my house it is 60 feet long and 30
feet wide there's a pattern to
everything in here and the way the
antlers are laid out that's the art the
reason I guess I display the antlers the
way I do respect for the antler respect
for the animal itself the shed may seem
full but when I look around I can still
find places to put the antlers as long
as I can get out and get around in the
mountains I'll continue to collect I get
the same thrill today 59 years later as
I did when I was a 10 year old and
there's very few things you can say that
about my wife has plans on me stopping
my daughter's never planned on me
stopping that I have no plans on ever
stop
[Music]
you know many of these meteorites are
billions of years old
imagine you holding that in your hand
the earliest part of the solar system it
feels amazing
[Music]
my name is Naveen Jian and I'm an
entrepreneur I started the collection
about five years ago and many people
would say that I probably do have the
largest collection of meteorites in
private hands then you look at the stuff
and people say it's just a rock until
you see in the microscope and say oh my
god what you have really in your hand is
spaceships I am just such a curious
person so when you're holding a piece of
moon in your hand it's not just a piece
of moon it really is symbolic of what we
as humans are which are explorers when
we get inspired what do we do we look up
every star that we see is really one
square inch of our own galaxy so when
something falls on earth we have no idea
what body it came from this is a great
meteorite this has 20 plus amino acids
so it's quite likely these amino acids
became the foundation for who we are
today so when someone says we're looking
for aliens all we have to do is look
around us we all could be aliens this is
a great meteorite but the white stuff
that you see is the earliest part of our
universe and many of these things are
formed at the time of the Big Bang there
is no doubt in my mind the space is
going to be a next frontier and it's
very simple reason every single thing
that we value on earth is in abundance
in space we are just nothing but a tiny
pale blue dot
[Music]
it can be beetles that come off a cactus
it can be the dried urine of a cow
little insects that grow on an oak tree
a chunk of lead that's soaked in vinegar
it's truly amazing
we're in Harvard University outside the
thoughts pigment collection pigment is a
very small particle of colored material
that is mixed in with a binding medium
the pigment gives paint its color the
force pigment collection has been
brought together over several decades we
have around 2,500 pigments we have a lot
of very unusual and very rare colors so
this is I think one of the more
unusually named pigments it's called
dragon's blood it doesn't come from
dragons it comes from rattan palms and
it gives a very bright red pigment the
unusual aspect of mummy has to do with
its source rather than the color itself
and that comes from Egyptian mummies and
it's the resin that's applied to the
outside of the bandages I think the
rarest color that we have is actually a
an entire ball of Indian yellow and this
is a pigment that is made from the dried
urine of cows that are fed only on mango
leaves
if you're looking at a work of art and
you want to understand what is original
and what's a restoration you will take a
tiny sample of pigment and analyze it a
lot of the pigments are actually toxic
so you don't want to handle the pigments
and then go out to lunch
there's a green called emerald green
that has an arsenic Center to it we can
use them for telling if something is
real or not people will say this is by a
certain artist and we can look at the
materials that are used and decide if
those materials were available during
that artists lifetime if not then we
have to look at who might have painted
that picture I can't pick a personal
favorite there it's like asking to pick
a favorite child no the other 24-hundred
would feel left out
I guess it is pretty green to me it's
not it wasn't just always all green now
I'm quite green
my name is Elizabeth sweetheart
and I am the green wavy
[Music]
everything is green I brought green
counter and then I got green knobs and
then all the accessories we even painted
the front door green if I find something
that I really like in terms of clothing
and what I wear I make it green these
are my overalls I grew up with my family
in Nova Scotia and they didn't know what
to do with me I wanted to be an artist I
started wearing green and my dad invited
me to visit Florida it was really
exciting for me to go because we hadn't
really connected and he didn't really
care for an artist the water is aqua
green deep rich Green's
I painted all the palm trees and from
that point on I started adding little
bits of green because it was like a
lucky day that dad asked me to go visit
it's been around 17 to 20 years I
continued to wear green because the way
I dress makes other people smile and say
oh the green lady can I have a selfie
with you
I think people really really like the
belief that you like something enough to
really carry it through when you're
young you tend to think you look good in
black as you get older you realize
colors so much fun I will continue to be
green because it's so positive I think
when it's not then I'll change to my
next favorite thing
you
you